الى قندهار زعيم حركه طالبان يغير معادله
المكان ليصبح الزمان في قبضته للسيطره
اكثر هبه الله اخ زاده يحول المتحدثين
الرسميين باسم الحركه ومسؤوليه الاعلام من
العاصمه الى قندهار في جنوب البلاد
وبالاخص المتحدث الرسميه ذبيح الله مجاهد
وبها عين رئيس مركز المعلومات والاعلام
الوطني انعم الله ثمن غالي رئيسا للثقافه
والاعلام خطوات اخون زادا تهدف الى احكام
سيطرته على الحكومه ووسائل الاعلام واعلان
مواقفه بشكل اسهل وفق مراقبين للشان
الافغاني
ياتي هذا بعد ان اكدت معلومات وجود
انشقاقات داخل الحركه
واستمتعا بقياده بارزه من احاديه اتخاذ
القرارات في اداره البلاد ابرزها وزير
الداخليه سراج الدين حقاني ما دفعه الى
السعي لتشكيل ما يشبه مجلس شورى للحكم
هكذا استطاع استماله وزير الدفاع محمد
يعقوب ابن مؤسس الحركه الملا عمر واقناعه
بالتشاور مع القاده من اجل العمل بشكل جدي
على تشكيل المجلس
في الاثناء مسؤولون بالامم المتحده قالوا
ان سلطات طالبان في شرق افغانستان منعت
الموظفات الافغانيات في المنظمه من العمل
وبالرغم من وعود في البدايه بحكم اكثر
اعتدالا من السابق فرض الطالبان اجراءات
صارمه منذ استيلائها على السلطه ليبقى
مصير الافغان رهينا بقرارات حركه تستمد
سلطتها من قوه السلاح فقط
بلال البجدين العربيه